I was browsing the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum this morning at
david pakman.com slash reddit some very
interesting discussions there that i
want to call your attention to encourage
you to participate there starting with a
discussion about an article on five
thirty eight.com pointing out that
donald trump's base is shrinking we've
been talking about this for a while has
the sort of hardcore trumpet base been
influenced by the scandal after scandal
after scandal you'll notice that TDPS
pat by watching here which is past
username on the reddit commented they're
saying i haven't seen his approval
numbers dipped below thirty six percent
though i wonder if that is the basement
for him yeah you're dealing you're the
basement sure absolutely you've got
floors and walls and windows right
there's probably analogies to be made
about all sorts of construction related
things but this is evidence that you are
participating there oh yeah yeah
and i think on the next one - all right
next on our reddit discussion forum up
by a post wondering about if michael
Flynn or anyone else in his team gets
charged with crimes do we believe that
Donald Trump will just pardon them which
is interesting it's an interesting
question and it's not one that we can
really definitively address right now
we're really kind of an uncharted
territory with this entire thing yeah
it's easy to get ahead of ourselves too
but if you notice I left another
insightful comment here which is perhaps
the question is if Trump does get
impeached and faces charges will pence
pardon Trump just as I Earl Ford
pardoned Richard Nixon exactly I think
the answer is probably but it would cost
him reelection it it could yeah it could
unless he waited and then did it later
hmm
anyway also from our reddit discussion
forum aren't the Republicans screwed
really either way and this is a very
detailed and extensive post that I won't
read to you but I encourage you to check
it out sort of exploring the ways in
which Republicans could be in a downward
spiral for the next two four six or
eight years whether or not Donald Trump
is impeached or removed or the election
and all this some have been suggesting
and I think that there's a lot to that
if the attention from the scandals can't
be diverted towards some kind of
accomplishments that will allow Donald
Trump
rating to go up from the low late high
30s and low 40s where it's been but
there there are growing scenarios where
no matter what happens it's not great
for Republicans yeah I mean again to
look back at history Jimmy Carter was
able to come in after the Watergate
scandal and he was looked at as a fresh
new face someone who was detached from
all the scandalous adventures of the
past I guess I like calling them
Adventures yet although in retrospect
his presidency is considered
colloquially by many as one in which the
least was accomplished in a very long
total was a decisive election victory
yes it was there's no doubt about that
and lastly from our reddit discussion
forum senator dick durbin just proposed
single-payer on Morning Joe just now I
have not seen that clip yet but that is
very very interesting and there I've
said this before and I'll say it again
there's no better opportunity to talk
about single-payer then right after we
get a disastrous scoring of something
like the second iteration of the
American Health Care Act from the
Congressional Budget Office this is the
exactly when we should be talking about
that and I'm glad Dick Durbin is join
our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash read it